hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about uh today's
order flow activity you know the
interesting order flow that came out uh
you know it was a Fed day and
you know the they kept rates unchanged
however you know they're sort of in my
opinion leaning you know they're quote
prepared to raise rates if appropriate
um
you know even though you know I see
people tweeting out off the FED has
paused well yeah they paused for today
but uh you know we still got I think we
got a meeting in uh November still I
think so I mean who knows we'll we'll
see you know a lot of the stuff that
comes out of the fed's mouth seems to be
uh make no sense at times and you know
I'm not an economist I don't claim to be
an economist I'm not going to sit here
and dissect this the words their
statements on on what they um you know
what they put out there because you know
as you know
um sometimes these politicians and even
the FED uh Governors and the head of the
treasury a lot of things that they say
just really makes no sense um at the end
of the day so again you know before I
jump in and sort of dissect the order
flow as opposed to dissect what uh the
FED came out and said
um if you've been enjoying these videos
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
that's important right because you know
one you want to be notified when I put
out a new video and two it helps the
channel grow right it makes more helps
other people find this channel
um you know especially if you leave
comments you know in the comment section
below especially you know if there's
something you'd like me to talk about in
the order flow
um you know something that's sort of
been
hanging you up getting you stuck in your
journey as an order flow Trader you know
that you want a little further
explanation um you know I love hearing
your feedback so your support does go a
long way in helping this channel grow
more and helps me create content that
you can learn from
all right so let's get ahead let's go
ahead and start with today's topic again
fed day okay and let's see here if I got
the simple bar chart here right this is
you know quiet morning going into the
Fed
let me close this down here then boom
the big drop down right we rally back up
to those levels and then sell off
all the rest of the day you know as
there there was some interesting order
Flow came in right here right ahead of
the FED
um
and you know it's one of those things
where it's like it's they scratch your
head it's like
who is doing this right I mean I don't
know maybe it's uh some Congress person
uh you know I mean it's no secret that
Congress people are trading
ahead of announcements and you know
politicians people in Washington I don't
know maybe they communicate who knows or
you know it could have just been some
somebody
you know I've seen guys do this right
I've seen Traders take out a you know
put on a big position right ahead of a
non-farm payroll number literally a
couple minutes before so a thousand Euro
dollars
um I've seen that but it's just one of
those things that just sort of you know
just says you sit there as someone that
watches order flow same really
because right this Market okay again you
know this is at 12 what time is this 12
43 you know one o'clock obviously all
the liquidity is taken out of the
markets
um you know all the others shut off and
then uh you know when the Fed
it says what they're going to say right
the big headline
but here you got 789 368 133 1033 rather
844 220 151 730 739 Market can't get
past this I mean if you were to add all
this up together just really uh it's got
a little calculator here 789 uh 368 10
33 844 220 151
7 30 7 39 it's almost almost 5 000
contracts 4874.
it's a big
that's a lot of volume especially
um you know on a day that's that's fed
day one I mean if you're looking back
here earlier right if you watch this
Market is it's a boring as heck market
today you know the volumes are very
light because it's fed day right no
one's really doing anything you're
seeing these bars you know some of these
bars you know 2 000 but that's about it
900 1100 800 725 500 600 868 okay not a
lot of volume going through
right even the volumes that are trading
it's about a hundred
if that and then that that's a generous
average I mean some bars are a little
bit more I mean some levels you know 162
basically 18 41.
you know inside the bar 30 99 you know
82 98.50 all right so it's nothing right
and then literally
you know this is about 15 minutes before
the number comes out big seller comes in
here okay now if you look at I just
happen to have the uh the depth map here
okay
44.95 okay and you can see it's Iceberg
right because you're seeing right here
okay let me just take it back tick by
tick
okay right here right Market is coming
down you don't see big size 147 on the
offer 182 on the offer right remember
this volume is at
95 44 95
.
where's the big order there right it's
it's an iceberg order right and
you know honestly you know you've seen a
big Iceberg order like that that's the
type that
if you're watching the footprint you're
going to see if you're watching this
right this Market depth map
now this is the ninjatrader one the book
map one takes it a bit further right
they'll actually show you you know sort
of like these Delta balls or whatever
they call it I don't know those big
balls so you can see a lot of volume
trading in there this is just showing
you the depth of Market
um
what am I getting my hands on the book
map but I'm just so I got a lot of stuff
going on with with order flow and you
saw you see 182 on the offer so you
don't see the whole size but it's
refreshing 138 but it's trading right
135.
right you don't see you know someone
plopping down here for a thousand
contracts or 1500 or anything more than
more than about a hundred
155.
you know 146.
you know 155.
you know people always big bid here 563
I think they're getting hard on seeing
this big bid Oh Marcus got to go up and
it does go up but again are you gonna
get long
at 12 53 right ahead of the announcement
in seven minutes
you know I don't know I I hasn't didn't
even get shoot I don't want to put
anything on but it's just uncanny that
that big offer that came in there
foreign
announcement right then we rally up okay
let's just mark this right let's
remember this area here
44.95 okay
fed announcement Market sells off to the
low right makes new lows makes new lows
makes new lows or no not lulos but
double double bottom here comes back up
gets past 95 comes all the way back up
here to 45 double O okay now again a
nice level 4 500 right nice
psychological level nice volume up here
1306. it is a bearish Prominent Point of
control as well which is you know a nice
sign
um let's take a look at the heat map
here
there's that big red bar down
then comes right back up here
okay let's take a look again
you can see it's right here 300 okay
you know it's decent size even here is
299 three quarters 326.
but as Trading
300 contracts
you're looking here still 300 so you
know it's an iceberg right that's how
you can detect an iceberg right if
you're watching a footprint
and watching a dome or a depth of Market
that's how you can tell there's an
iceberg here okay now again this I I
drew this line out this 95 area because
you know I'm always curious to see how
when the market comes back to it however
it's a Fed day okay now I I personally I
think it's a little bit fishy that oh
close to 5 000 contracts gets sold right
ahead of number I mean who knows I mean
again I'm not trying to insinuate
anything you know it could be somebody
just maybe flattening their position who
knows you know but uh The Conspiracy
Theory theorist in me something's up
um
you know it's like uh the whole thing
with the Maui fires you know those poor
poor folks over there people
you know my wife and I hey maybe we
should paint our our roof blue
um it's like
okay so the number came out so I'm not
looking for this 44.95 area to be you
know
um you know this was resistance now we
broke down through I'm not looking for
it necessarily to be resistance at this
point because after this bar prints
right after the FED announcement sort of
what happened to the left of that in my
opinion is rear view mirror I can't use
what I've saw here necessarily in my
current analysis because everything's
changed right everybody was waiting for
this announcement come out one way or
the other and they're adjusting their
portfolio and everything so the flows
afterwards are going to be much stronger
than the flows before it okay
but this is important to me point of
control on the extremes the bearish
Prominent Point of control it's a
bearish order flow ratio 0.54 so I know
there's stopping volume up here right
everything all the alerts are going off
in my head of
you know a market that's about to turn
and it came back up here tested it again
again only traded 38 and again how can
you tell that's an iceberg right well
you can see here it's only showing 238
okay
373 came right back up tested that
came down
right and then that was it okay
and then went lower lower eventually
took out the lows a nice little bounce I
thought the market could potentially
rally off this
off this low here at 44.70 just based
off of what I've seen in the order flow
um you know that bearish value area here
bearish sorry bullish not bullish
bullish bullish
but it's just going sideways and again
I've got a lot of bullish value areas
here the Market's not rallying if
anything it's putting in you know this
is our little swing high off this low
puts in you know bullish value or
bullish value or bullish evaluary comes
back here with a lower high than this
one bearish value area
starts trading down again I get a
bullish Prominent Point of control but I
already had a bunch of bullish things
here
and the market hasn't rallied so you
know I'm not necessarily looking for
this Market to all of a sudden rally and
it doesn't it sells off right makes a
new low sideways new low sideways new
low
it's a little bit of a bounce right it
hits this new low here at 64 and a half
going sideways got the bullish value
area here starts to Rally okay you know
decent Deltas coming in off the low 382
738 528
so then nothing then it goes sideways
all right people asking how do you know
you know Market's chopping
well if I'm getting bullish information
bullish order flow like here
and even over here and the market can't
rally
to me that's not necessarily a sign of
chop it's a sign of a sideways activity
it's a sign of a market that's
struggling to make a move if Market's
struggling to make a move chances are
it's either going to go sideways like it
did and then eventually fail right or
break down in this case
okay and then boom rug gets pulled again
and we trade all the way down to
you know this area down down down down
down down even into the cash close after
the cash close kept making new lows
before finally just flat line down here
but um yeah I mean that was it you know
the interesting order flow people say
did you traded we know why are you
talking about this stuff you don't trade
it you know there's certain days you
should stay out of the market I I know
that day is a day I should be staying
out of the market right no one's putting
a gun to your head saying you gotta
trade every single day right because why
is particularly because of a day like
this the volatility in the market from
98 and three quarters all the way down
to the low here at 84 then the next bar
continues it down to 78.
okay and then it rallies back back up to
99. you know that's why you stay out of
these markets now there's some Traders
honestly they're very Adept in picking
up changes and they can trade it kudos
to them more power to them you know I
applaud you if you're one of those
Traders but again not everybody trades
the same way not everybody has the same
um Outlook of the market time wise you
know being in a trade and risk
management wise all right so just bear
that in mind so that's going to wrap up
this video on you know today's fed
activity or say fed activity but fed day
with the order flow so again if you find
these videos helpful for your
understanding of order flow let me know
and you know be sure to subscribe to the
channel
if there's any topic you'd like me to
cover be sure to leave a comment in the
comments section as well so thanks
everyone and I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye bye
thank you